welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm very excited to
be joined by
farook mohammed who is one of the
co-founders of
digital gurus and in 2016
they sold this business to the rethink
group which is now
on the board of um and this group
consists of four recruitment brands
including
digital gurus generating over 150
million pounds in turnover
they employ over 100 staff within the
group and farooq started
digital gurus during the financial
crisis in 2008
with two business partners and in the
last 12 years has grown this business to
80 plus staff
turning over 54 million pounds a net
free income of 12 million pounds and in
this actual business dg now operates in
london
manchester sydney and dubai farook
welcome
good to be here thank you as i was
saying where i always like to start
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
so i really thought about this and i
thought over
my uh career of interviewing recruiters
as well
and i've i've interviewed over
last count it was over 1500 people
for recruitment consulting positions
within dg right so there's been a lot
and it was always the core things that
we looked for
um there were some bonuses on top but
the core things that we always looked
for
was hunger and drive which you can
probably bunch up together a willingness
to
learn and humility and ambition
and the reason it was those things was
because we couldn't teach them
we could teach market sector specific
knowledge we could teach
how to go and find a good cd we could
teach how to network we could teach how
to
um do a boolean search we could teach
how to
go in find a customer but we couldn't
teach those core values
so let me just relate to them hunger and
drive obviously we wanted people who
wanted to really push themselves because
when you're when you're in recruitment
the business that we built was one that
was
less cracking the whip and more
self-motivation
so we wanted more of the carrot than the
stick and what that meant is that you
had to be self-motivated
you had to be able to go right what am i
wanting to achieve
for myself what is it that i'm driving
towards the company will give you the
infrastructure but without that
hunger and ambition that willing
willingness to win
there wasn't a lot that we could do for
you there would only be a certain amount
and i believe this there's only a
certain amount that the stick could even
get you to
you know right how many calls have you
made today how many customers have you
spoken to after a while that becomes
repetitive and boring
if you've got that willingness to win
that ambition to learn
that ambition to push yourself that will
just keep going indefinitely
that was a core value that we looked at
the other the other thing that i
mentioned was humility and willingness
to learn right
unless you are willing to listen to
people that have been in the trenches
before that tell you to do in a certain
way
that you're able to go actually let me
try and do it that way
let me try and experiment in a different
way to what i think it should be
then you're gonna struggle um if you're
if you have that
ability to go i'm not an expert in this
area or let me try it in this different
way or let me experiment
you're going to end up being far better
than you would if you
didn't so those were some of the key
criteria for us it was always the same
thing
now like the the whole you could always
go to should you hire experience or
non-experience
right and my answer to that is that you
if you
don't have those core qualities in the
experience people
it doesn't matter you have to have those
core qualities whether you're
inexperienced or an experienced so if i
was hiring a recruiter
10 years worth of experience in
recruitment didn't have those core
qualities all i felt they didn't have
those core qualities we wouldn't hire
them
yeah so that's the recipe that you
always look for yeah the key parts of
the recipe yeah
i i've never met honestly i've never met
anyone
who'd set their career goal as being a
recruiter
so therefore most people who come into
this
industry have come in it without meaning
to come into it
and they need to have some core key
characteristics
that means that everyone's learned the
skill of being able to do recruitment
so they must have had some core key
skills and for me those are the key
ingredients
yeah interesting well hopefully
recruitment is becoming a bit of a
career choice for
i'd like to think that it's changing
that's slightly changing and
i think there is definitely more people
that want to get into the industry but
really interesting insights so a lot to
uncover here
you've been on a long journey where i
want to start when doing my preparation
for this
we've got to start with this mike ashley
story we just have to
start with it right so to give some
context and correct me if i'm wrong
from what i learned about you through
because you worked in recruitment for a
year and a half
and you and your two business partners
started to think about
we can do this better than the business
that we're in and start to formulate
digital gurus in
a shisha lounge on a weekly basis
talking about
what we're gonna do what you can do
better so you had that that i guess
that naiveness to be like no we can
definitely do this right and just that
hunger to
to make things happen and from what i
heard you talk about this before
is that you decided all three of you
that to kick-start this journey
you need 10 grand each that's that's
what you need to
to to buy in to start this so why don't
you share
how you got that 10 grand because i know
you didn't have it but you found a way
to get it so why don't we start that and
how did some gurus started
absolutely so i didn't have the money
and i was like right where i'm gonna get
this money from
and this was sort of like in the back of
my mind
anyways i i used to live with a bunch of
mates on
uh one of my mates worked for a large
spread betting firm
and he comes home one night and uh it
just goes oh you'll never guess what
mike actually lost 60 million quid
last night uh
making a bet i can't remember exactly
what a bet was but he lost and i was
just like all right okay
back in those days there was news of the
world and you'd
you'd often see little adverts on the
tube or
wherever will pay for stories
so i was like okay maybe i can make some
money out of this right
obviously betraying one of my friends
trusts totally like
stepping over the line but needs must at
this stage and he still to this day
doesn't know he's still
to this day doesn't know and uh so i
call up news of the world and i call up
a few of the newspapers and i go look
i've got this story how much would you
pay me
news of the world go 10 grand they must
have known rounded numbers work right so
they say 10 grand and
uh i uh i i arranged to meet this
reporter
and he arranges to meet me in this hotel
on
like on the thames in water near
waterloo on the thames i remember this
hotel was in
and it was like dimly lit and i walked
in there and it was
absolutely how you'd imagine a news of
the world reporter
to look right i'm just saying
stereotypically i'm not saying it will
look the same but this is how i imagine
that person to look and he looked
exactly like it
shiny suit slip back hair the whole
works
and he sits down and he goes right so
tell me the story told him story tell me
how you know
told him all of that and he's like well
we have to verify
this story we have to call up mike
ashley so he um
he just calls him up he like you know he
calls up
this this secretary or something like
that anyway he gets through to mike
ashley and
goes might look we're going to run this
story that you lost x amount of
uh 60 million quit on
monday night or whatever whatever night
it was and we're gonna run it on sunday
mike actually just turns around and goes
now that's not true i lost 120 million
quid because i had the same bet on with
someone else
a firm same bet with a different phone
so anyways this
story ran it was a double-page bread
which i've still got i still got it
in my house and they paid me 10 grand
and i used that money to start the
business up with so
literally about two weeks later we
started the business because i went to
the guys i went lit i've got 10 grand so
i've got my share i have no idea where
they got their share but that's how i
got my money i sold
absolutely my best friend absolutely
yeah so yeah actually i had to get you
to share that
i just thought when i first heard you
talk about that i was like that is just
that is mental
um but i think that says i think that
says a lot about
the type of like you clearly someone
that
makes it happen clearly from from what
when i've heard you talk about your
journey and you take action
um i think um i think it was an
opportunity and it was something that we
really wanted to do and an opportunity
came
about and and we took it you know
ethically was it right
uh probably i'm not 100 sure if it was
totally right
but uh it was an opportunity that had to
be taken at that time and you know what
it worked out
so to start a digital gurus
union two business partners right yeah i
haven't got a whole lot of recruitment
experience how how much
experience did your business partners
have at this point
uh one of them had eight months and one
of them
had around two and a half years
and uh what was funny is that we thought
that was enough
and you know what it might have actually
been enough in terms of recruitment
experience
but what it what we didn't have was any
experience of how to run a business
run a business yeah yeah and that's a
completely different skill set
and we we realized that relatively
quickly
so what i heard you talk about which i
found
really interesting and i don't know how
common this was
when you started this in 2008 was that i
heard you talk about that in the first
two years of you starting digital gurus
like what you decided to do and take
your own initiative on was like
pick the brands of experts and ask as
many people as possible
for advice yeah absolutely it was really
wrong
so like i said we didn't have any we
didn't have any experience of how to run
a business
at all so we started to reach out to
people that one that we saw
as competitors um and two that we
thought we'd want to
um be able to network with them learn
from them and whatnot we never saw it as
a way of that
but you can't speak to your competitors
for us it was always okay so we should
be talking to
our competitors to learn about the
market for that for us to be able to
learn off them
and see what mistakes that they made
potentially and if they were willing to
share so
we reached out to a few larger companies
back then
and you know what every single one came
back to us and said yeah calm down let's
have a conversation
um and we slowly over the next two years
learn how they build their businesses
how we should build ours
we reach out to the experts we made a
ton of mistakes before we'd reach out to
them
we were able to escalate our learning by
reaching out to those sort companies and
it was absolutely invaluable it was
really one of the key reasons we
succeeded
and what would you say were like i don't
know the top
one to to free i mean you may be asked
this before but like thinking about that
and how valuable that was
yeah top one to three things that people
shared of you that you think really
stuck and
were really instrumental in how can you
grow as you can imagine it was
it was all a lot of it was around stuff
that you wouldn't learn in
recruitment sales so it was like
financials
how should you structure your financials
what sort of accountancy should
you should how should you be leveraging
off your invoices so things like cash
flow
and scaling up and then there was things
like business plans how do you
strategically
grow from three to thirty
what what numbers what metrics do you
need to hit for your next hire
so one of the key things we we learned
from reaching out to somebody
was that they used a metric system where
they'd be like right
every time we get these amount of things
happening so it might be
interviews or jobs on um and a
conversion between them we're going to
hire somebody new
every time we hit that metric we're
going to hire somebody new because that
was their signal
to say the market is big enough for you
to go and trying to track
attack it they had a systematic way of
doing that
so that was a real key thing the other
key thing was that
we just didn't know how to grow
our business using uh cash flow
so we were just funding it ourselves
right and somebody came in
one of one of the guys that we were
working with and said
now you should be using this facility so
your perms should be paying for your
contractors
and your contractors should be paying
for your perms so just leverage the
amount of invoices that you've got going
out
we would just go in right if we've got
that much money coming in from perm
we'll use that to pay for our
contractors instead of using both sides
it was totally naive so lessons like
that and ultimately the other big thing
that we learned was
what type of culture it takes
to succeed what are people attracted to
you know so i go in and go right
why do people want to work for this
particular firm what is it about them
so little things like office
design and brand and marketing in terms
of their website
so i'll give a real example when i went
to one and they had a semi-decent site
i remember this is 2008. recruitment
agency websites in 2008 were
horrific so we were like right right
our industry was digital design and
technology so we're like right
why don't we design our website
like a design agency so it looks really
slick really professional
because what we think that will do is
convince
candidates and customers that these guys
know what they're talking about because
look at their site
they look completely different to a
recruitment agency website
totally so we actually professionalized
that we went to a design and branding
agency
not uh like oh we specialize in
recruitment now we went the other way we
said we're going to go to a specialist
that designed for products
and they designed our website and it
blew out the market
completely changed our brand from a
challenger to
these guys are serious overnight what
you saw over the next 12 months was
every recruitment agency then changed
their websites to match it to try and
catch up
so we had a huge edge in terms of
candidate
and customer perception just from
branding and that came from reaching out
to other recruitment agencies to see
how they were doing it and the ones that
we were sort of like trying to emulate
we noticed that their website tended to
be better than the others
and i say we were like right let's try
and blow them out of the water so
there's little things like that those
were their key
three learnings i would say that that's
really interesting
definitely want to dig into you talking
about your
hiring triggers that you now know from
like that's early on right but the
hiring triggers
are sort of non-negotiable for you now
but quickly on on branding because yeah
i heard you talk about this
before that you like you're talking
about that generally gave you an edge
and also led to where you ended up in
terms of being seen by the businesses as
a business
to potentially buy or invest in etc
yeah and i think if i don't know what
your thoughts are on the landscape right
now but i think
obviously the recruitment industry as a
whole marketing has become
even more important and you're talking
this about in 2008.
right yeah so there's still companies
completely on the fence about this
investing in martin these things so i
guess what i want to ask you was
early on at that time and maybe you can
share what you sort of spend now but
like
percentage-wise roughly how much was you
investing in marketing out of the money
that you was putting
we were aggressive we were aggressive
with marketing we were spending at least
10 percent
ourselves um and then then we were doing
uh sweat stuff as well right and what i
mean by that is that
there were loads of networking events
that were going on that
we we weren't uh they weren't ours right
so they were in our industry
that people were running and so we would
approach those events and say we'd like
to sponsor it
and we'd get like a discounted
sponsorship but what we used to do was
ask them to say if they said pays a
grand a month to sponsor this
we'd say we'll give you 500 quid but the
remaining
will work for you on the night so things
like
we'd be on the door right with the guest
list
we did that strategically because we
knew that people letting people in
we'd get to meet them face to face yeah
we'd get to know them we'd introduce
ourselves
and whilst we're doing a favor for the
event it was also raising our brand
awareness
so we're strategically doing gorilla
marketing and really trying to get our
brand out there
i would say that you have to be famous
for something
you have to be unique and it's like
anything like think about
a shop that you want to shop at if you
went to their website and it looks
slightly tatty it
you'd start to think should i be giving
my money today's business is the product
gonna arrive
um all the things that are associated
with that so for me
to really stand out in the marketplace
now and in the future
is that you've got to be you've got to
look slick your website's going to look
slick your message is going to look
slick your
and the way that you present yourself to
the marketplace candidates and customers
has to be spot on
you've got to be famous for something
you know i think that the market has
evolved from being generalist
into being specialist and the more
you are known for something and i've and
i've heard a couple of people on this
podcast
talk about this and i totally agree the
more you're known
for something being famous for something
the better you'll become and that
if you think of it from a candidate's
perception what do candidates hate about
recruitment agencies
they hate that they don't know what
they're talking about they hate that
they
are never got back to and they feel like
they're just
a piece of transaction for them they
don't feel like they're getting value
if you can convince the candidate which
is the core part
of a recruitment process is the
candidate is to go right
i've got your interest at heart
i know what i'm talking about because
look how much i invest in my product and
myself
in the way that i present myself to my
customers um i'm going to treat you like
the most important thing in the world
you're going to differentiate yourself
from the rest of the marketplace
because even now to this day we just
don't do that
the way that i look about the
recruitment industry is that we should
treat it more like the sports industry
treat
there and start so like for example the
sports agency market will work with a
certain
amount of candidates and they'll go and
present them to the marketplace
if i was in recruitment now in a
specialist vertical i'd say right i'm
only going to
deal with the top four in that industry
every single month i'm going to deal
with top four
don't know who they are but i'm going to
deal with the top four i'm going to find
them and i'm going to work
only with them and i'm going to tell
them that i'm going to put them at the
center of it
i'm going to use my brand i'm going to
use my um
knowledge of the market to take them to
market to get them the best uh
um job for them the way the sports
industry does
and then what will happen is over a year
you're working with 48 to 50 if you're
in on the perm side of the market you're
working with 48 to 50
and your brand and network just becomes
bigger and bigger
because you're able to specialize that
for me is the way that the market should
be rather than generalist
so you've shared she shared some of the
things that you learn
from people's advice and and then you've
taken action on branding marketing
what went really wrong for you in the
first couple of years digital gurus
where did you go wrong what mistake
people want to know the mistakes you've
made
what what mistakes the mistakes that we
made was that we
didn't get the rights or professionals
to help us we thought that we could do
it all ourselves
right so what i mean by that is that we
went cheap on
things like uh financing or accountant
right typically what i
see is that when companies set up their
recruitment agency they'll go right i'll
use my mates accountant or my dad's
accountant or somebody in my network's
accountant
rather than going you know what i'll
spend a bit more but it'll save me
tons in the short medium and long term
and what i mean by that is that
we had my dad's accountant wrong v80
returns late
v80 return just little things like that
and they all add up right because
in recruitment it is a specialist
industry the volume can increase
really really quickly especially if
you've got a contract book you need
specialists so we should have outsourced
more
to specialists that knew our market and
we would have saved tons of money
and we would have grown quicker we
wouldn't got fined the other thing that
we should have done
is that we should have had more um
specialist advice from non-exec
directors earlier
we did get one we got one after a few
years and it really
was i think it was critical and i was
getting to a cell
but again it was that naivety and that
arrogance i would say
to go oh now we know what we're doing
we'll scale it up and and that just put
us back a couple of years
yeah just on that i had a question come
through and i think this is i sometimes
get asked because of the network
i have do you know any good neds right
so i guess the journey that you've been
on now you you can look in a bit
um look back on this but like any advice
for people business owners listen to
this that do want to find the right
id because there are a lot of people
that haven't walked the walk or
say that they can help with something
but they can't or whatever right so
i guess you just said that it was
pivotal so like
if i if i'm if i'm asking you for as a
recruitment business owner like what
would you encourage me to look for
because it's personal to me in my
business but what would you say
be the non-negotiables when considering
an nd for my recruitment business
you've got to get on with them that's
the first non-negotiable um
and you've got to be able to
the other non-negotiable i would say
would be that you've got to be able to
have
really um difficult conversations
and if you're not able to do that as in
that trust factor isn't there then
there's no they're not going to really
add value
so again it comes down to the key
criteria of how you hire recruitment
agencies you've got to have humbleness
about you
you've got to be able to have a
willingness to learn and if you're able
to do that they will absolutely add
value to they will scale
your business up a lot quicker than you
would be able to do yourself because
they'll stop you making mistakes
you know they'll absolutely introduce
you to experts that will help you scale
your marketplace i can tell you
without doubt without our non-exec
we wouldn't have been able to scale that
business and sell it at the time that we
were
we might have been able to do it
eventually but not in a timing-wise that
we did it in
because they stopped us or they
eliminated mistakes that we were making
that we weren't even aware of
and they were able to introduce us to
people that were able to scale our
business up a lot quicker on the
professional side
yeah so it's not even just them the
individuals actually you then get access
to their network right because it's in
their interest
absolutely yeah so just on on the
first part their mistake really
interesting and probably a common one
like what looking back now
like what do you think has been the most
important hire of all the glue
that's really enabled the business to
push forward if that's a sales director
an ops director people manager like what
do you think
has been like and absolutely like
someone maybe you
could have got in the business earlier
that you think it made an even more of a
difference what would you say
uh i think um a sales director in the
business earlier would have made a huge
difference um
in terms of scaling the business up i
think that would have been a critical
hire but i would say honestly
the critical hire was
i'm loathe to say this in recruitment
business but it was an accountant
it was sorting out it was sorting out
all of the um all of the mess that sales
people do because we're not experts at
that we don't really want to take care
of that stuff we want to do the exciting
stuff of selling and making money and
making a difference in people's lives
that's what we're brilliant and that's
what we want to do and i think the
critical hire was
um those of you actually the marketing
director because they helped us
explore explode our brand and really
take us on to the next level
it's very difficult to say that one
particular salesperson
was critical i would honestly say that
every single hire that comes through the
door from the sales side is critical
because they add to your brand they add
to your network they add to your sales
numbers
um it's very difficult to separate
somebody out but in terms of one of the
things that you mentioned earlier
around mistakes as well i think one of
the mistakes that we did make was that
we didn't ourselves
hiring somebody once the business
reached a certain size
to run it and we should have stepped
away more ourselves we were hands-on for
too long
so i think a sales director managing
director
could have taken a business on even
faster even quicker
i think that would have been important
okay
so you've spoken quite a bit around
early on in dg so keen to dig into like
leading up to
selling to rethink stuff about i know a
lot of people are keen to hear about
this so
just final thing around this there are
as
i'm sure you're aware the large majority
of the recruitment industry is made up
of small micro
recruitment businesses right so there'll
be a lot of recruitment business owners
listening who are at that 10 head mark
or 20
head mark right and i'm sure a lot of
people seek
your advice but who write that so i
guess what
like if they're listening right now and
they're at that stage of their business
and they do
want to scale that's obviously important
that they do want that they know that
what would your advice be to them if
that's where they're at in their journey
let me just break that statement up for
a second right
so there's two reasons that um
recruitment companies start up one is
either for a lifestyle
and because you want to have a better
lifestyle and you want to run it in that
way or two you have a really clear
mindset that you want to scale up a
business and sell it
and the two don't often combine
because if you're running as a lifestyle
business you're taking more money out of
the business
if you're scaling up and building it to
sell it you're putting more money back
into the business
so for those who want to sell their
business this is really
important to know if you are doing one
million
quid profit and
uh plus you will have one to two
checks chasing you if you're doing two
million
and above you'll have eight to ten
checks chasing you
uh in profit so it's really important to
know that
massive difference if you're doing one
million and below
unless you are super strategic in a
niche area that a business wants they're
not going to come and look at you
right so you really got to focus in that
profit line
that's the thing that's that's the key
differentiated in terms of
acquisition in terms of scaling up
you've got to be able to look at your
marketplace and go right
in this marketplace how much is there
that we can
um scale up in terms of headcount what
are our metrics that we're looking at
and it could be jobs on
it could be interviews to jobs on and
the two interlink
and it could be sales how much sales are
we doing before we bring our next
person on it could be how much
percentage margin are we doing in profit
so if we're selling
a million quid and we're putting 10 of
that on the bottom line so 100 000
do we want to increase that or do we
want to put that back in the business
what are the metrics that we're looking
at so for me we always drove it
really really simply on we want to hit a
certain amount of profit
we want to hit this conversion rate on
our profit so we used to look at how
many
uh how much jobs are in that area that
we're getting through monthly
how much interviews does that convert to
before we'd hire our next one two
three four hires based on that data so
we'd always run it data led for those
businesses that are out there right now
going right should i hire another person
should i look at another two people
should look at up three people you've
got to break down your market
how many jobs on have you had in that
market in the last couple of months
how many jobs do you think you've missed
out and it's a bit of a finger in the
air exercise how many jobs do you think
you've missed out on
how many uh what does the market say in
terms of growth
over the next year two years and you can
find this data online
for example if you're in a marketplace
like ai
what does the market growth look like
over the next five years
in terms of percentage growth anything
over five percent
growth in that marketplace year on year
you should be investing you should be
looking to invest
because that market will accommodate
that extra person
the organic grower that will accommodate
that extra person so that's what i'd
look for
so if you're a business right now and
you're like right i want to sell my
business and you've had a couple of
speakers before whose ambition is to
sell it the magic number that they're
looking for without them being totally
strategic
as in they're a specialist in a certain
area is one million plus
minimum for those that want a deal
guaranteed on the best terms
two million ebitda interesting
and just really quickly i've had a
couple of people can you i know
like some people have messaged me before
like he shouldn't like what
when they say nfi and netflix income
ebitda like what do they mean can you
just just do that in layman's terms for
people did you know i mean because i
think that's beneficial
nfis operate in profit so in recruitment
um where you have turnover as well
because you've got
contractors in in a lot of them it's
what you're left over once you've paid
all your contractors
so it's your sales number once you've
paid all your contractors so
for example you might have 100 million
in turnover but once you've paid your
contractors
you've got 10 million left over nfi is
that 10 million
also known as operating profit also
known as sales
ebitda is once you've paid all your
staff
once you've paid all your costs what's
left at the end of the month before tax
right and depreciation effectively
yeah and that's typically what's used to
value businesses and everything else
into that figure
yeah it's it's slowly changing in the
industry but in recruitment
it's usually usually four to seven times
in transactional recruitment
rpo is slightly higher rpo is usually
six
to ten so so what what wait what do you
mean what do you mean by that sorry just
to be really clear on that
multiplier on what you're making and
what you can get so if your if your
profit in a year is a million quid um
usually in transactional businesses so
the ones that like
right um we do this market we charge 15
and it's just every time you fill a job
you get a certain amount of
money that's transactional uh usually
they go at five times multiple so if you
did a million quid
and somebody makes an offer your
business is probably gonna go for five
million quid
right if it's five times multiple
whereas in rpo because they are
multi-year contracts
they go for more so they'll be like
right we did a million quid
same amount of profit but they'll go for
six million if it's a six-time multiple
yeah okay go left so fruit you sold this
business to the rethink group
and digital gurus became part of the
rethink group in 2016.
so like how far out from the exit or
from that cell
because obviously you're still involved
sorry so maybe not the right terminology
but how far up from that sale do you
start planning
the process and what was the most
difficult part in that practice to get
there
would you say oh right in terms of how
far out from day one
straight up we had a real clean idea
that
we were going to build this business to
sell it um
from day one it was there was no we
weren't interested in lifestyle we
weren't interested in taking any money
out we were like we are going to build
this business and we're going to sell it
and it was
a real key strategic thing
and i would say to any business um
entrepreneurs that are looking to scale
up their business or looking to start a
business or looking to sell their
business
you've got to have a really clear idea
that you want to sell the business
because it will determine your decisions
so that was the first thing the the in
terms of
when we were going to sell to rethink we
knew maybe
we knew we were going to sell the
business probably a year before we
definitively
were like right in the next year we're
going to sell this because we had
multiple parties that we were talking to
private equity other options
that were on the table and and just on
that quickly
sorry sorry it's a button but a few i
think a few people interested in this
like
how did that actually come about did you
proactively look for it
did i don't know did you give the
potential business proposition to
someone and they broke it out to their
network like i think yeah
great question like i said network they
came from on non-exec
it came from my non-eclipse um
and what you'll find is once you've got
a certain
brand and a certain amount of profit
the market becomes aware of it and the
market will come to you
i would encourage those that are really
focused on selling is
to not proactively go to market because
you'll tend to find that you'll get a
better offer
coming to you there's loads of agents
you've got
everything straight away haven't you
you've got leverage straight away
totally it's like anything like you look
we all work in sales we know what works
it's like um you'll have loads of agents
you'll have companies that are listening
right now that'll have agents
approaching them saying oh yeah common
we we've got interested parties in your
company and we'll take it out to market
and they'll charge your price to do that
but most of the time that's not going to
go anywhere so if you're going to
negotiate those types of deals don't pay
any cash upfront and say we'll give you
a higher percentage on sale
if you get the right network involved
and i'm telling you there's
plenty of companies out there sitting
there looking at the marketplace looking
at who's doing what profit looking at
their areas of strategic weakness where
they go to the market and go right we
need this area
they'll be aware of your brand and it
will come to you
and your uh your advisors as well
will be well aware of what the
marketplace is doing and will be able to
introduce you to the right places as
well so
a great question and it's important for
the thing that i'd be aware of with
certain things like that though it takes
a lot longer than you'd realize in terms
of the actual
act of practicing
i thought it would take us i thought it
would take us maybe
three months um and it took us from
start to finish a year
i would say okay and it was full
dedication
so i i basically started to just focus
in on that
so it took me away from business and any
potential com
um companies that are thinking about
that you need to be fully aware it's
going to take you away from your
day-to-day activities and you need to be
able to do that
and to be honest if you're not able if
your business is not able to function
without you being able to
take a step away from it anyway you're
not ready to sell
so it should be able to survive without
you yeah so so this is my sort of
question i think this is
be interesting to get your thoughts on
this because i think this is the part
that i don't
think i think that it's sort of a gray
area
right and there isn't complete clarity
so be good to get your thoughts like
what do you think
going through that process and now being
in um a group that i i guess
looks for businesses that you can invest
in like
what would you say is the most valuable
part of a recruitment business that an
investor
looks at
it's profit stone cold profit
they look at sales growth and they look
at profit is the business on an upward
trajectory
if it is great what numbers is it doing
on the bottom line
then they look at secondary factors does
it address a market weakness in our
brand uh in our service line does it
address a market weakness in the market
does it have a great brand in itself
does it have great people
and it must do because it's on an upward
trajectory
what's the sort of leadership like and
does it integrate with our own
brand and offering in terms of culture
culture fit things like that
but stone but they won't look at you
first and foremost you can have the best
brand in the world
the most amazing known brand
brilliant outgoing staff all of that
amazing stuff but if you're not putting
it on the bottom line
they're interested
did the sale meet your expectations
it met my expectations in terms of we
wanted to do it for strategic reasons
so it met my expectations and it took us
from one level to a completely different
level
in terms of uh and i i personally
when i learn a load
did it meet my expectations in terms of
the downsides that come with
selling your own business because
ultimately what comes with that is that
that lack of
you have the final set you're now part
of a
team and leadership i think it's very
difficult to
ever say that it's better to go and
compromise your own final say
than having your final say if that makes
sense like i'd much rather
be able to make that decision myself um
and i think most entrepreneurs are going
to be built that way that's why they did
it in the first place they're like
they like the risk element and they like
to have the final say element as well
because like how i know i asked you this
like when we just spoke and stuff but
like
you knew 2008 from that shisha lounge
like we're gonna build a business to
sell so like how
oh i know you're still getting involved
like how did i actually feel like how
did you feel about you
like how did you feel it's it's a
really interesting thing so the day that
we signed
a lot of people um usually feel really
weird about it because they are parting
with a piece of their soul effectively
yeah you know you built this thing it
was your intention but because we were
so laser focused and
going we're going to do this from day
one whereas it was just a
natural conclusion so for me personally
it was a sense of fulfillment a sense of
achievement
and i it didn't feel like oh my god this
is an emotional thing
it was very no you've you set a target
you hit the target
and i think that the camps of people out
there that will sell their businesses
will fall into one of those two camps
some will feel like oh my god
this is such an emotional wrench and i
totally understand that and others will
feel like
tick that box what's the next thing for
me what's the next target
yeah so what i think people will be
interested in through because
so you mentioned profit stone card
profit that's what you need to
look at for your business to be seen as
really valuable or more valuable than
other businesses but
i think some people be interested in the
secondary parts right and i know
we understand that the first part is
more important so
what did what did your you mentioned
people right so what i think what people
would be interested in is like what did
digital gurus leadership team looked
like or like what was the structure so
obviously you were just focusing on the
deal but like what was the actual
structure of the business and what did
that look like in terms of the people
leadership and where they were
when you was like yeah pretty much there
or
then yeah being considered as a really
valuable business
you said something really interesting
and important there the profit
is important and the most important
thing that companies look at
but you don't get that profit without
all those secondary things you do not
get that profit without a world-class
culture you do not get that profit
without world-class people you do not
get that profit without a world-class
brand
and you do not get that profit without
servicing your customers both candidates
and and clients really really well
consistently over the years
that's really important for every
business out there to hear the one thing
that i would encourage you all to take
away from this is obsess about the
process the results take care of
themselves
obsess about the process you know if you
do not look after your candidates if you
do not service your customers needs
the profit's not going to be there if
you do not look after your staff if you
do not
create a culture where they want to all
work together for the for the same goal
the profit's not going to come it's just
not going to come so that's the thing
that i would really emphasize
in terms of how we structured the
business we were very
bottom-up culture and and i'm a big fan
of bottom-up cultures i'm not saying
that top-down culture isn't right but i
was a big fan of bottom-up we
gave a lot of creative freedom to our um
management team so they had a lot of
freedom our dubai office was run
um with some sort of save back
to base camp like we all had the same
brands but we'd
adapt things for localization so how
much basics do you pay compared to uk
how much commission do you pay
australia was very much the same thing
we had some
central themes that were running
throughout all the businesses but
the localized leaders also encouraged us
to go this is bespoke for us and we ran
it that way
our managers had freedom i i really
wanted
my managers to be able to hire and fire
as they saw fit and usually hire right
to make those mistakes to learn for me
it was important that they developed
that themselves that they were able to
learn and develop and grow
and that was a real key part to our
success um
so we had a really flat structure we had
a bottom-up culture
it wasn't very centralized it wasn't
very controlled and that was
uh part of our success but there were
key themes that would run throughout the
business
minimum standards in terms of
expectations minimum standards in terms
of activity
how many jobs you have to get on how
many uh interviews you have to get kpis
are really really important but they've
got to be
important to serve the the process has
to be right to get the outcome so it
wasn't like
you've got to make 20 million phone
calls today well if you had a certain
amount of jobs on already
your focus was probably more on getting
candidates
you know to able to source that or if
you had a world-class candidate your job
was to go in
market that candidate out to customers
that needed that that skill set
it it wasn't prescriptive it was what
you
particularly needed for your desk at
that particular time in order to get the
outcome that you wanted
but the outcomes were all the same you
know if you were a certain level we
expect this outcome from you this is the
breakdowns that you need to do in order
to get that outcome
yeah so just as we come to the end here
i've got there's just
um i've got five sort of quick file
questions that i definitely want to
ask you but okay so we took i think a
lot of a lot of
it always comes up in a conversation i
want to grow my head can i
hire more people right and i think
you're touching on it here but like
what would you say you have done as a
business and
i think you were just talking about it
like let's just talk a bit about
retention
of staff right i think everyone always
talks about need new hires need new
people with great if we could get this
hundred head counter
like what you're talking about bottom up
culture which clearly contributes to it
probably but
like where do you think had the most
impact on retaining
your best staff and creating more of
those role models and digital gurus and
those success stories that
continue to cultivate that bottom-up
culture
the key to retaining staff was to have a
common goal um
and for everyone to be facing in the
same direction and moving in the same
direction that was really really
important in terms of
retention and i would say retention is
more important than attraction if it's
the right people that you're retaining
in terms of um retaining and attracting
you've got to have a really
forward-looking goal
the goal has got to be ambitious it's
got to be hard people like that people
want to be part of
a journey that's big ambitious
slightly dangerous they want to be part
of something that's going to be
like well guys we're going for this we
want to be part of journey we want you
to be part of the journey and that's
what i mean by that collective culture
if everyone is in it together facing in
the same direction pushing together
that is so powerful as a force
so so powerful and the other thing that
you have to infuse that with
is fun you know like
we're in a really challenging year this
year but recruitment is that one
industry where you've got to be able to
enjoy it it's
hard the job is hard you've got to be
able to have a laugh
and if you can have a laugh together
it's so powerful so so powerful i mean
to this day
some of some of the guys who have moved
on some are still there
will come up with instances where we had
a rough week
right we missed our numbers for whatever
reason or whatever
and somebody would
leave from the front and go right i'm
just going to stop work today we're
going to go out on an extra long lunch
we're just going to commiserate together
we're going to
just get back on it and then we'll come
back and we'll crack on again
little things like that that were
entrepreneurial that were different
that everyone was in it together made a
massive difference
so that's a huge part of success for me
and i think and i think that's the
interesting thing right because i think
if you think of a typical small business
it's probably
things like that that they haven't spent
time on if you think about it like that
maybe they might not
they might not have really clearly
communicated their values or they may
not know
be really clear on their their purpose
and if i think of the recruitment
business environment i was in there
there's 12 of us and
there wasn't a common goal it was more
of an individual goal we were all bought
in and we're a team
but actually we didn't know what the
common goal was and sometimes i think as
a small business because you're worrying
about
well you've got to get cash in the bank
and you've got to crack on right
so i guess just i think a lot of people
go yeah i get that but like how
how can i know you just got to start
right but what how can you start that
process and start communicating that
common goal
should you if i'm listening to this now
i'm like you know what actually we don't
have a common goal
like do we need to do they need to pull
everyone together and be like right
why are we doing this like what what's
in this process that's
one way of doing it that is one way of
doing it what is the purpose why are we
all here
what is the common goal that we're
trying to do has that got to be bigger
than just numbers is it gonna be do you
know what i mean like what what is this
who's motivated by numbers no one no one
is motivated by numbers let me tell you
that straight
people are motivated by a goal by a
mission we were really transparent that
we want to grow this business to sell it
but we're going to have a laugh doing it
that was ours that was our bespoke thing
so we were absolutely comfortable to do
that somebody's out there right now
again right we haven't got a common goal
speak to the staff what do we want our
common goal to be and i like
get some advice from them they'll tell
you what they what they think they
should be and if you're in a small
enough business
you can design a common goal together
you know and if you're in a sort of
larger business get your management team
get them to speak to their staff and go
right come with some key themes let's
sit down together let's brainstorm it
let's
let's have what are we working towards
and if that thing is not
really if it's just numbers these
motivated by numbers i'm sorry about it
no not yeah
it's what comes with the numbers that's
that's the thing isn't it that's it's
that it's like
okay yeah why are we doing this nobody
wakes up in the morning going right i'm
doing this because i want to make
i want to hit my 10 grand target on my
20 grand target this month
what are you going to get with that 10
grand what does that bring
what is it important for me and over and
above that what is it why is it
important for the business and if you
can really get everyone tuned into
what's important for the business as in
the business and the individual goals of
line
so powerful we've got five questions for
you
let's go if you could change the
industry what would you improve
i would make it into more of a uh
we cultured enemy culture what i think
the
industry gets wrong is that we over
emphasize the individual rather than the
team and what that leads to
is that a few people end up winning
rather than the majority
so i would fully change the way that the
industry
awards success i would i would
democratize it far more
what what book have you read that's had
the most or biggest impact on you
um the book that i've read
is principles by ray dalia
which sets out really clear goals
and life principles that he set that
were able to guide him when
he was uncertain and i just copied it
and i started doing the same in
different circumstances and it was
fantastic if you don't know who ray
dalio is you
you need to check him out is i mean the
stuff that he's come out and now said
and just shared everything he's learned
and
yeah you you need to know who ray dalio
is
quite frankly yeah and it's a great it's
a great book
um so if you could write a linkedin post
that could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant
across the world what would you want it
to say
god that's a that's a challenging one i
would want it to
um i'd want it to be positive so i'm not
going to be specific because that's too
much of a challenging question to answer
but i want it to be positive
i'd want it to be forward-looking so
focusing on the future
and i'd want it to reflect something
like
a reflection of how
appreciative people
that are in my position are of what
those people do
that job is phenomenally hard
it's thankless a lot of the times and i
would just be like
do you know what you guys are amazing
thankful
for working with people like that let's
keep cracking on at this
and let's keep being successful so it'd
be on those themes
yeah i like it interested in this one
what
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
uh oh god probably on a night out if i'm
honest
or like biggest or like the but the
first time that you probably paid
yourself out of the business i guess
might be a bit different for you but
i think it's always interesting you know
what i i i'll answer that slightly
differently what did i spend my first
commission check that i really enjoyed
spending that money on right that wasn't
classical uh
i come from a really working class
background my dad's a taxi driver
and he single-handedly raised
me and my brothers and did all of that
stuff so the thing that i enjoyed buying
the most with my big commission check
was i bought him the fanciest car that i
could find that he wanted
and a smile on his face he didn't say a
word was it
that was that was yeah it was priceless
that was that's what it's about
last one i and i've slightly changes for
you but i guess what what
what is the ultimate goal for your
career for rick
to work with two things meaningful work
meaningful people
i want to work with people that um i can
learn off
that i love working with that are hungry
ambitious
and want to want to achieve and
meaningful work
in terms of that we're making a
difference to people's lives so those
two things are my key drivers
meaningful work meaningful people
combine them together
job done for explain absolute pleasure
excited to see
what's next thanks tisha